[Musique]
allez
allez ça va on y va
bien révèle
quand il s'agit de rentrer les animaux
de la savane l'équipe des soigneurs de
beauval doit suivre un ordre précis
c'est toujours des rhinos parce que
c'est les animaux qui sont enfin plus
pressés de rentrer le soir en général
puis quand ils traînent devant le
portail après il peut y avoir des
conflits s'ils attendent trop après on
rentre zèbres des antilopes an dernier
les girafes au milieu puis chaque espèce
attend son tour sagement habitué à
l'exercice quotidien
les précautions reste de mise surtout
quand c'est tout un troupeau qui déboule
à vive allure comme les antilopes les
zèbres ou autres hippotragues etc et les
hippos tracks sont passés du coup cela
qu'il est en pleine
en journée tous cohabitent en plein sans
pour autant se mélanger le soir chacun à
son box pour plus de sécurité les
antilopes et les gnous parce qu'en fait
ils ont des cornes n'ont vu qu'on n'est
pas là le soir pour surveiller si un
conflit ou quoi ou moins là on est sûr
que personne va se battre ou quoi et
puis on sait qu'ils ont leur de rillieux
granulés dans la ménagerie les plus
grandes se sont-elles diot de leurs six
mètres elle domine la mêlée mais la
girafe reste un animal craintif
facilement perturbe abl ce jour là la
petite kim ya trois ans fait des siennes
c'est qui on y va
c'est rien ma fille
bug sur la moindre chose inhabituelle
donc là en l'occurrence sur roue va
finir par y aller parce que le reste du
groupe de toute façon il rentrait donc
un va pas vouloir rester toute seule
jusqu'à trouve le courage nécessaire de
passer le portail
faire attention parce que en fait on est
assez proches d'elle qu'elle serait
quand même grandement de grandes pattes
dans la panique si elles ont peur de
quelque chose du coup elles peuvent
facilement nous donner un coup de patte
sans le vouloir
[Musique]
est parti
une fois tout ce petit monde rentre et
les soigneurs s'assure que les boks soit
bien ferme et les animaux peuvent alors
se reposer pour la nuit avec nourriture
à volonté